part of the action see the views are
already going up yeah oh [ __ ] oh Jesus
Christ
[Music]
welcome back everybody to an awesome
episode of the careful boys slightly
shorter version am I right uh today we
do have Colleen back welcome back
Colleen
that's the excitement all right so uh
Steve go ahead
[Laughter]
oh wow this is a big moment it's a big
step uh no we're gonna do low well
something that we like to do every
couple of months is have a JK creative
meeting when Bart's available we usually
do it over Zoom not when I'm available
everyone when everyone's available it
just so happens we have Bart in the room
with us right now oh that means Bart's
available it's helpful that Joe's not
here so we can get stuff done to be
honest it's when Anthony is available
actually Anthony's a busy boy he's busy
don't don't table turns on me but
Anthony Anthony showed up during his
buddy's bachelor party for our [ __ ]
creative meeting last time dude he was
yeah he was he was not that I have his
back I don't I don't like him yeah
because you guys hate each other yes
correct but you're fair I'm gonna be
fair like him he hates me it's different
so so we're gonna do our creative
meeting right the [ __ ] now okay right
the [ __ ] yeah let's do it so so who's
got an idea
ah what the problem let's start with the
outsider let's start with somebody who
can recognize our problems from the
outside clean if you can tell us the
things that you just think are whack
about this entire operation do you watch
the show but they don't do better it's
so so cool that's the problem we gotta
we gotta get our guests to watch the
show that would be big my outside
perspective it really matters because I
don't watch the show okay that's pretty
cool but you've been on the show so I've
been on the show yeah I think I'm here
right yeah I'm here have you seen an
episode
I've seen a clip
on Instagram which are very active on
Tick Tock which are active on now too
I hit that demographic of people who are
guests on the show that don't watch
there but you know that's just me wow I
think you should have a counterpart so
like if you were going to say something
but you changed your mind you tag
somebody else in they take your seat and
they have to say whatever that you were
gonna plan on saying so they should be
tag team matches absolutely so like
everybody has a counterpart dude
whoever's sitting at that table with Joe
that's a tough one try to do that with
Biden and Trump hats you can attack but
but can I ask this is it okay like so if
you're Joe right now and I'd get tagged
in
then I can go like this yes but then I
can also go like this oh [ __ ]
and then we go nowhere yeah yeah we
don't go anywhere the zoned out zone so
who has a creative idea for JK and and
how we can fix this whole thing how do
we take JK
to the point where we don't get our pay
cut that's a good
thing it's such a low Point hold on wait
people left in the room are not Bart
blame it blame it on the ads dude we're
blaming on the ads we're not blaming you
we're not blaming on you we don't blame
it on you
it's not always about the leadership and
the people who are at the top that make
the decisions that run the business
part personally just be and I'm just
speaking for myself right now I love
that you show up to JK in like five
different cars
[Laughter]
well I get my
once you get a rock hard steel hard
boner I get a rock on her phone I love
it that Joe's got three [ __ ]
residences and addresses he lives in
Vegas he lives I'm so happy for you guys
opening all your guys's business is
[ __ ] inspiring talk about the ads
more please yeah yeah yeah the algorithm
and the ad let's talk about your new
lift kit bro it's sick
flood lights bro
it doesn't even flood
you're in a master plan Community every
every time he rolls up and he goes yo
check out my truck I got this new cover
it looks great Bart
let me check out my Civic and he goes by
the way you guys have to pay for lunch
today
no but
but that's why I fly jet sweet X to save
the money it's been going up jet speed
that surprisingly going up
no so my favorite things about about the
JK creative meetings we will do we just
did a two-hour meeting it was two hours
long not kidding right correct correct
two and a half okay give or take we um
we then get sent meeting minutes of
everything that was talked about in the
meeting yeah like paragraphs thanks Mike
thank you Mike
what has changed
since the creative meeting this was four
months three months ago to be fair to be
fair this is the first week of the new
JK initiatives this is this is this is
the first week of Adventures Adventures
episode tomorrow so stay tuned for that
yeah and the first thing that we did on
the list is get rid of Joe and replace
him with him which is really smart which
is I think is a good he got voted out
fair and square he got voted out we
don't jump topics as quick yeah and yeah
and we got someone that could wear hats
better than that is right and hold
weapons figuratively and literally yeah
so that's the first thing and then we
have what JK Adventure tomorrow which I
can't go to that's cool so what are you
talking about I can't go you're bailing
I got a thing are you being serious yeah
I got a bro I got a birthday shut up
you're trolling no one has birthdays I
do I do have a birthday in the seventh
but how dedicated I am to JK I'm I'm out
I'm not going to the birthday thing whoa
okay so what is it what are we gonna do
tomorrow I'm not gonna tell you stay
tuned give him a sneak peek bro so can
you explain what the adventure
initiative is so the fans understand
uh when we used to have our JK films
Channel like one of the things that
people really enjoyed watching was me
and Joe go try different stuff like
whether it's food or activities like we
did professional wrestling and stuff
like that and we thought it'd be a cool
idea it's tired she's bored what no no
we thought it'd be a cool idea to get
everyone involved and we all gonna do
something fun or go eat something and
and and hang out outside of this room to
show a little bit of more camaraderie
and some of the cool Shenanigans you
know what I'm talking about
okay and that's every every Friday that
week not every Friday we'll see we're
gonna we're gonna test some formats out
if they like it we'll continue with it
like uh we're gonna have Ryan's sad
corner on Saturday which might have a
piano did you know there's a piano right
there yeah oh yeah we have the piano
back there Saturday where uh Ryan can
actually score a story live so we got
some stuff like that just testing out
new formats see what happens just just
the adventure initiatives all I asked
for we didn't need the extra we just
wanted to be sold in the adventure
initiative all the minutes dude yeah
dude no surprises anymore yeah now we
gotta do another creative medium all
right that Bart's the stripper standing
outside showing her tits the traffic
that's why we have these windows
actually
how about some of the things that like
people like in the comments of JK
suggests like there have been a lot of
times people want long-form videos they
want like a podcast yeah they want like
like two-hour [ __ ] with one person
well that's too bad we just cut off the
records in half yeah because you're
gonna do the opposite yeah we cut it 40
because our pay got cut 40 yeah yeah
that's funny because it's actually 40 is
it 20 minutes to 12 minutes it's very
good you're a nerd
who is going to laugh about percentages
like that when I'm watching this later
I'm gonna I'm gonna freeze that look
that Anthony gave you and then I'm gonna
print screen the [ __ ] out of it and then
I'm gonna turn into a sticker later bro
we gotta make t-shirts with Anthony's
face this guy's trying to [ __ ] sell
the likeness and rights of his face so
you can get [ __ ] school [ __ ] that's
another thing only five G's a month
though that's another thing that JK fans
have asked for repeatedly is careful
boys merch really yeah all the time but
Bart says there's no bandwidth for it
how do we do it what's the first step
just get it made okay and then we put
and put on a website what's the first
piece of March I think just just to care
to something that says careful boys
would be kind of sick wait I did a poll
on the IG of all the logo stuff that I
the guy with the skull right yeah they
like that one and they they really want
a jersey like yours no way 13 in
September if you want a third penis at
10.
by the way I brought it so we're gonna
hang it there tomorrow if there's a
cheap way to get that even if it is a
shirt but it's just printed with that
people want the [ __ ] out of that shop
that was such a good idea by the way
that was genius we gotta like put that
out if you guys are down let us know uh
in the comments and we'll do pre-orders
so that we order the exact amount
because I have no idea how many people
five really excited people or if it's
like ten thousand you know hey yeah most
likely five we want them they won't make
five of them so we don't make ten
thousand if they wear it on their own
personal Instagram and start getting bad
oh yeah because right wasn't there a
problem with with the beguiled the old
enough for kisses clip did great on
YouTube did great on Instagram got
totally banned on Tick Tock and we and
we took a strike for that so amazing
it's a Clint Eastwood movie yeah we're
not made from the classic it's a Turner
Classic Movie they play it on an AMC and
[ __ ] or whatever playing on Hawaiian
Airlines see it's on the fake JK uh news
other tick tocks but also it's it's just
us reacting to it it's not like working
yeah but it says some [ __ ] about you
know child I don't know you didn't put
hashtag ad since they are the ones who
paid us for the second round of
marketing campaign for the beguiled
which is what this whole thing doing a
brand deal with the guy yeah Jesus
Christ we've actually hashtag sponsored
beguiled Clint Eastwood it's uh Tick
Tock seems to be more strict on [ __ ]
you know humor involving the where it's
the expense of a child why do you sound
like you're censoring yourself right
yeah because I'm trying to put it I'm
trying to put it nicely because he's
trying to post this later on Tick Tock
speaking of JK creative how about a
round of applause for this man right
here no I don't
I'm trying to maintain that synonymous
it is anonymous because people
editor uh leave that in
people always message the account and
they're always like who the [ __ ]
running the [ __ ] people ask me all the
time so clean you have no other like
suggestions for the channel what could
we be doing better or worse what do you
think we could do or feel free to talk
about your favorite things about this
place well you guys did say that
whenever somebody gets up and it's more
active and not just sitting down you
guys tend to get more views that is true
people people do love like bodily
actions right right bodily actually
let's see see the views are already
going up oh [ __ ] oh Jesus Christ
oh sorry Anthony okay do you think the
throttle that was choreographed do you
think the bodily actions have to make
sense to the context of the story
that's just gonna be cool
that's what you're wanting right there
it is yeah that's it that's it just that
clue really can you actually do a head
spin on the chair yeah dude don't this
is how [ __ ] this is
holy [ __ ] you're [ __ ] gay engagement
engagement engagement mine is wild guys
spit it spit it
that's the second time hey try hey do it
again please
are you are you so good at falling that
it doesn't hurt anymore there we go see
oh
[ __ ]
dude wow
are you so good at following that it
doesn't even hurt yeah that's right
he ignored you the first time assistant
choreographer sorry that was CTE talking
holy [ __ ] good job that was incredible
thank you so do I get 40 more I don't
think anyone yeah
and that's it for the short horses
nailed it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]